die alle wagen den großen schritt diener
und kevin schmid mit ihren kindern amira
und drohen ihr ziel australien
der ehemalige tagesschau moderator hans
jörg enz sein abenteuer für den in den
kongo monika und trainer toni mit den
töchtern chiara und selina ihr neues
leben beginnt im wüsten emirat dubai
sandra und danken ghana
die beiden übernehmen eine farm in
kanada und claudio candrian und der ispo
net der traun ein eigenes haus auf einer
karibikinsel
[Musik]
am flughafen zürich nur noch eine stunde
bis der ehemalige computer supporter und
car show für ketsch mit nach australien
ab fliegt er muss in der neuen heimat
alles vorbereiten
seine frau diener seinen sechsmonatigen
sohn horn und seine knapp vierjährige
tochter amira muss er noch hier lassen
[Musik]
also das ist wichtig
für die junge familie ist es ein
schwieriger moment
[Musik]
erst in einem monat wird ehefrau dina
mit den beiden kindern nach kommen ehe
man kennt bereits in ein paar tagen mit
seinen neuen job als touristenführer an
mitten in der wüste australiens in alice
springs
[Musik]
unbequem
[Applaus]
standard
dem 8
er war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einige tage später
während kate in australien das neue heim
der familie vorbereiten muss hängt nun
alles an diener schmid sie muss im sankt
gallischen ufi den umzug ganz alleine
managen und auch familienhund bo hat
eine abenteuerliche reise vor sich
nach sechs stunden ist das haus geräumt
der container geht auf und davon nach
australien wie auch bald und bodo
[Musik]
ehemaliger tagesschau moderator bekannt
als der mann mit der fliege in wenigen
tagen wandert der 58-jährige als
entwicklungshelfer für zwei jahre in
eines der größten krisengebieten der
welt aus in die demokratische republik
kongo
doch bevor es heißt auf und davon gibt
der hobby musiker mit seiner band
galgenvögel hier in weinfelden ein
abschiedskonzert
[Musik]
erst dann sei variabel
ganz einfach der tiefen profi will in
afrika journalisten ausbilden
ich habe immer gesagt ich will
irgendwann mal nachbar russland tafel
und steam ist dort wo dynamik hat
allerdings muss an dynamik und mit mir
gesagt er kriegt die wenigsten sie
derzeit ohne wirklich machen was
passiert und dann geht es los
das abschiedskonzert der band
galgenvögel hansjörg enz präsentiert
seine passion von ufo
[Applaus]
beraten wird
die hammer
ja es geht mir gut
dann sei
[Musik]
bliebe sowie
und wie
jk
[Musik]
sogar
auch in niederbipp im kanton bern
herrscht aufbruchstimmung dieses
typische schweizer einfamilienhaus war
zehn jahre lang die heimat der
vierköpfigen familie mazzoni nun geht es
auf und davon nach dubai und auch hier
ist es mit monika macho die die ehefrau
die den umzug ganz alleine bewältigen
muss ihr mann reto lächelt nur noch vom
plakat an der tür der ehemalige swissair
pilot ist schon in dubai und arbeitet
dort als pilot bei der fluglinie
emirates
bald folgt ihm die familie in die wüste
früheren arbeitgeber fürs leben lang bis
du funktioniert bis wurde setzt
natürlich dort auch andere discounter
und da wird einem bewusst ok als er ist
nicht stellen arbeitgeber fürs labor und
in dubai es ist jetzt einfach so lang
wie süß gefoult und wenn es ist immer
dasselbe was labor parat für spiele-fans
noch kohle das dank internettelefon
skype ist papier eto'o nicht ganz so
weit weg
[Musik]
also ich jetzt mit rumänischer für uns
war klar so positiv war ich jedoch im
sky knolle drei auf den beinen im kanton
zürich packen derweil sandra und danken
gano für ein abenteuer in der wildnis
die beiden möchten eine form in kanada
kaufen ehemann danken erfüllt sich einen
kindheitstraum
er ist die nordamerika auf einem
bauernhof aufgewachsen
für sandra gal ist es neuland während
sieben jahren haben die beiden auf dem
golfplatz unterengstringen gearbeitet
dieses sichere leben geben sie nun auf
für ihre abenteuerliche zukunft in
kanada
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jahrelang haben sie für ihren traum
gespart und sich minutiös auf den großen
moment vorbereitet denn nun realität
wird doch vorher müssen gardos noch ihre
wohnung abgeben
die vermieterin schaut genau hin doch
alles geht gut erreichbar aber es ist
schon komisch
fazit zum nachweis dass hund endlich
treten werden dass man sagt auch die
chance schnellgang in maienfeld im
kanton graubünden wohnen sie noch der
rhb lokführer claudio candrian und die
postangestellte theres pronet die beiden
wollen es in zukunft gemächlicher
angehen
ihr traum ein haus auf der karibik insel
margarita und nie mehr arbeiten
ja wir nehmen die allod knappheit
overhead eigentlichen geschäft von nur
52 betriebe 60 60 mir nicht ums andere
mal jetzt so lange bis mögen
[Musik]
deshalb packen sie es nun die beiden
knapp über 50 jährigen
[Musik]
der letzte arbeitstag von claudio
candrian bevor es auf geht nach
venezuela
seine tour führt die nacht die säntis
und dort muss er übernachten
[Musik]
claudio kann es kaum erwarten nach
venezuela zu kommen auf die karibik
insel margarita weg von den kleinen
widrigkeiten des lokführer alltags in
der schweiz
[Musik]
dass sie dann nicht unbedingt dicht
zugluft
spar mit
die branche wachsen
[Musik]
knapp 30 jahre seines arbeitsalltags hat
er hier im führerstand der lok der
rhätischen bahn verbracht
[Musik]
pünktlich um 21 uhr 19 fährt claudio in
disentis 1
[Musik]
die
ein letztes mal schließt er die
lokomotive und das bahnhofsgebäude ab
lokführer ist ein einsamer job sagt er
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja ja ja die überraschung von theres ist
gelungen alle sind sie gekommen
geschwister freunde verwandte alles gute
für deine zukunft auf der insel
margarita steht auf dem heißluftballon
der in den bündner nachthimmel entsteht
[Musik]
genau
australien auswanderin diener hat
unterdessen mit kindern und hund
bordeaux unterschlupf bei ihren eltern
gefunden
per computer bild telefon lässt sich
diener von ihrem mann kelbert der
bereits in australien ist das neue
zuhause zeigen zum ersten mal sieht ina
ihr neues heim in alice springs mitten
in der wüste australiens
[Musik]
ich gehe jetzt mal für mindestens zwei
jahre auf das ist sich großes ziel und
dann die situation nun bestimme wie faul
service ist es dass man mir das
vorgestellt und ist es so wie es aussah
bach und weiterhin vorstellen und dann
entscheiden wir lieber mit und schickt
dann halt die schuhe
so wie jesus ist ein wirkliches der
schule sein erwidert oder es ist keines
stelle sich überhaupt nicht so wie man
sie drohend hand oder tanz kam hatte der
hai heute fliegt ein weiteres
familienmitglied ab der grosse schweizer
seinen und bodo darf nicht mit seiner
familie reisen eingesperrt in einer
hundebox fliegt er alleine nach
australien und muss dort nach seiner
ankunft vier wochen in die quarantäne
ok
ein hund ist sehr sensibel was gefühl
auch belangt und wenn ich vor dem hund
da wieder von gabriel und das sollten
kunden mit ruß als es passiert ja und
dann glaube ich es gut so wie es ist zur
gemacht man glaubt sowieso wir schmoren
war nicht einem flügel ist willi flip
video ist er fliegt voraus und dann ja
dann einfach dass er das gepackt und
überlebt
[Musik]
20 stunden flug nach australien vier
wochen quarantäne
all das liegt vor brutto ob er wohl die
strapazen gut überstehen
nicht
[Musik]
afrika auswanderer hansjörg enz ist
unterwegs zu seinem lieblingsplatz dem
nussbaumer see in der nähe von
frauenfeld
ein letztes mal noch bilder hier hohe
tanken bevor es losgeht in die
demokratischen republik kommen
dieses land wird immer wieder von
bürgerkrieg und gewalt erschüttert
meistens auch die frau
das turnier ist lieber mit mit mit
angespannter lag halb vortrag und zu
holen
rang kommt also nicht erst sein wenn
jetzt ein land einfach weiß du hast
sicher ein problem da funktioniert stadt
einigermaßen wer es mag ja da ist da es
ist so so schön das okay jetzt ein
letztes foto seines lieblings ortes das
gbg soll moderne telefon dass wir
nachher bild und sind zum schluss auf
die computer du als bildschirmschoner
ist das besonders pervers überladen
überhaupt nicht mit seiner maschine naja
[Musik]
inzwischen in niederbipp bei sonys den
dubai auswanderern die 10 jährige selina
hat heute ihren großen abend sie feiert
mit ihrer schulklasse ein abschiedsfest
ich hoffe du gehst nicht auch nicht
[Applaus]
antonius haben im ersten stock ein
improvisiertes kino eingerichtet
dort schauen sich die kinder einen film
der komiker von divertimento an
doch selina hat wenige augen für den
film als vielmehr für diesen
klassenkameraden jco was nichts von
seinem glück
ihr geheimnis für celina später nun
ihrem tagebuch anvertraut
doch vettel
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen ist auch in
niederbipp zügel tat
der aufbruch nach dubai oder johnny
schon sehnsüchtig wartet rückt näher
wenn wir das nicht mehr brauchen weil
ich jetzt mal live videos sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
emirates airlines der arbeitgeber von
redondo nie bezahlt einen großen teil
des umzugs der streng katholisch hält
sich in grenzen und auch selinas heiß
geliebtes klavier kommt mit nach dubai
nach wenigen stunden ist man sonys
container gepackt dubai wartet
bleibt nur noch anzustoßen auf das neue
leben in der wüste
[Musik]
derweil am flughafen zürich sandra und
danken grano sind bereit für kanada
danken muss abschied nehmen von seinem
götti militär
[Musik]
wow
zeltweg
[Musik]
sandra und tanken haben keine eigenen
kinder umso schwerer fällt dankende
abschied nicht zusehen wie die kleine
thea aufwächst und größer wird
ich sage jetzt einfach tschüss und
ordnen und fertig aus jenen vertrag
weiter damit deutlicher war schwierig
härter
und dann heißt es auf und davon nach
kanada
[Musik]
mache ich immer da gedacht ist aber
eigentlich
[Musik]
auch tennis bund hat einen schweren
abschied vor sich bevor sie nach
venezuela auswandert sie besucht das
grab ihres sohnes daniel eines von zwei
kindern aus erster ehe
vor acht jahren im alter von 23 jahren
hat sich daniel das leben genommen
mindestens einmal pro woche besucht sie
seitdem sein grab
[Musik]
es geht immer besser aufgeschlagen und
jan autoliebhaber mir kroaten die ak
schätzt das grab bereits hochgeladen hat
im prinzip ist ja immer noch im herzen
somit nämlich erhalten
[Musik]
am abend heißt es auch für claudio
candrian und ins kofferpacken für die
trauminsel in venezuela claudius ehrgeiz
maximal zwei koffer mitnehmen und kein
übergepäck und somit wenige jeans und
ein paar kopftücher ein sparsamer start
ins neue leben und zwar in der letzten
und ganz
bereits am nächsten tag am flughafen
zürich haben claudio und teresa allen
grund ein erstes mal nervös zu sein
claudio country ans nerven liegen blank
dabei haben sie doch alles so gut
vorbereitet ist die reise nach venezuela
schon zu ende bevor sie überhaupt
angefangen hat lange gesichter bei
claudio und dabei waren sie so früh am
flughafen und in ruhe ins neue leben
starten zu können
[Musik]
doch schließlich klappt es doch noch mit
den tickets dafür bleibt kaum mehr zeit
für den abschied von der familie
[Musik]
sie spiegeln
und claudia parys rennen ihren traum zu
venezuela entgegen
[Musik]
sie könnte
sie haben es geschafft
flug condor 1110 nach venezuela ist
startbereit
damen und herren noch plakativ gesagt
ist jetzt ganz herzlich willkommen
aber der flug von frankfurt über
[Musik]
auch diener schmid bricht heute mit
ihren beiden kindern nach australien auf
noch knapp 20 stunden flug trennen sie
von ehemann kennen
nach dem stress der letzten tage hat
dienern und plötzlich zeit etwas zur
ruhe zu kommen
nachzudenken
sie erinnert sich an den schlimmsten
moment in ihrem leben vor zwei jahren
musste sie die tod geburt ihrer zweiten
tochter erleben auch ein grund warum die
familie heute auswandert
ich bin mit wer ins spital
dann haben wir gemerkt dass sie nicht
erlaubt und dann habe ich sie ganz
normal geboren und zog in ein anderes an
das passiert
vorher hätten noch her
die sich
die sich einigermaßen trittin ecopy will
man einfach das lager ist so kurz ist
also unklar
sie ist also
es kann alles passieren wo man etwas
wirklich ernsthaft darüber nachdenken
und merkel nehmen die zitrone jetzt
haben wir nichts machen wir nur der
vorräte und damit 60 mm sagen hey warum
haben es nicht gemacht wenn sie mir den
tisch
und so gemalt
bis sie und viele km h sein und sich
zwar schon aber dann müssten wir mehr
ziemlichen probieren wir uns gut gemacht
während unser traum probieren
auch hansjörg enz will seinen traum
leben
deshalb muss er heute abschied nehmen
von seiner frau anita herzog von
konstanz nach frankfurt und dann per
flugzeug in den kongo anita enz bleibt
in der schweiz
die beiden sind seit 31 jahren
verheiratet
meine damen und herren gleich zwei
gruppen
spaß
[Musik]
hi
ja
[Musik]
abschiede mag er nicht sagt hansjörg enz
zwei jahre wird er von seiner frau
getrennt sein
ja
du merkst market ist also ich es so
[Musik]
also weniger fahre ich mit tunika oder
und und wieder den ruf gottes und und so
den denkinger vieles an alle und ist
vieles anders als du nicht denken dass
es für die wo gott ein kleben -
smartphones für die anbieter ist alles
gegen zu ändern ist musiker kommen
[Musik]
noch acht stunden bis familie mazzone in
dubai wieder vereint ist für den flug
ins all
51 der ausgaben 14 uhr fangen einsteigen
sitzen alle zusammen natürlich danke
monika schwester ursula und ihr freund
rosen zum flughafen gekommen
ursula ist die gotte von selina und dann
gilt es auch für sie ernst familie
mazzoni startet in eine ungewisse
zukunft
[Musik]
sie stiegen im winter mit david kaum
einmal hin
[Musik]
licht und sind
das schaffen
sandra danken gano sind bereits in ihrer
neuen heimat angekommen
nun fahren sie durch die unendliche
weiten nordamerikas zu ihrer künftigen
farm am lake manitoba in cannes ab dort
erwartet sie ein grundstück von 800
hektaren die fläche von über 1000
fußballfeldern und spazieren muss egal
kosten für druck
ein einsamer coyote begleitet die beiden
kanada auswanderer auf dem weg in ihr
neues leben
[Musik]
in australien wartet sehnsüchtig auf
seine familie
nach über einem monat kann kevin schmid
seine amira wieder in die arme schließen
[Musik]
die zwei älteren
familie schmid ist wieder vereint das
abenteuer australien kann endlich
gemeinsam beginnen
[Musik]
sie stiegen in die lücke mit david haye
emirates flug ek 88 ist im anflug auf
dubai dort wartet schon ganz aufgeregt
reto man schon zwei monate muss der ohne
seine frau und seine beiden mädchen
auskommen
[Musik]
als auch die betreuung und zeigt was
selbstbedienungsladen
das abenteuer kann beginnen
sie stiegen mit der frage kommen
[Musik]
die stadt bukavu im osten der
demokratischen republik kongo
[Musik]
auch hansjörg enz ist mittlerweile in
afrikas realität angekommen
in einer holprigen realität autofahren
geplante früheren als handelte und vom
autos kommt nur höre dass man hatte
anderen autos weg und der mit links und
rechts und zwei probleme ist das rüber
und drei gehängt und war mit einem maße
das urteil und die sind dann im raum
hansjörg enz und sein neues leben wir
davon in der nächsten folge sehen sie
auch nächste woche unsere venezuela
auswanderer auf dem land für ihr
traumhaus
doch aus dem traum wird ein albtraum in
kanada entdecken sandra und danken gar
neues zuhause mitten in der prärie
verlauf damit in dubai lernt eine
schüchterne selina mazzoni ihre
zukünftigen klassenkameraden kennen
und in australien kommt familienhund bo
nach vier wochen quarantäne endlich zu
schmieds nach alice springs
[Musik]